previously on the forest i was wondering
if we could make a drawbridge with the
with the crane thing right oh no guys
please come quick
mark are you in some sort of trouble
they can throw
fire oh god it gallops
probably something with eight legs you
know it was six legs
okay oh eight legs oh eight legs wait
one only count one two three
bubbles right it was six oh what is that
big baby
what actual perfection is this what's
happened to me
and then go over here hey
there we go so you're telling me this
card just doesn't go on drawbridges
some number of legs is coming i gotta
get the sled
so you're you can't go from that side i
just want to let you know
people going in the water
wait can they burn
ah i'm on fire okay fine how am i still
on fire if i'm underwater
this poor bird i forgot that this was
all for the purpose of us
building your house up above the camp
you got sidetracked
i'll admit yeah that's accurate i would
say
it's accurate to say we got psychedelics
casting bridge
no where am i going
no try it wiggle side to side you can do
it you're so
close i would like to submit a bug
report
what is that wait wait go up raise it
no no no no no no not this cartoon
wait what are you standing on what's up
help help
[Laughter]
oh my god so this is um a part of this
now
you're just built into it now i don't
think i'm gonna let go for oh boy there
it goes
maybe that will prevent them from
crossing the bridge
oh oh my god don't do that
oh no i don't know if this is better or
worse
raise me up yeah raise him up raise him
up raise me up
nope oh okay hang on i'm i'm free
possibly
oh okay
those are just down there from now on
aren't they
i yeah we can access the rocks on them
yeah well thank god we can get this i
kicked it up i was like
it's now this rock how'd you do that i
just walked in the water and it flung
upward
wait kick it some more kick the other
one oh i'm trying
don't seem to hmm pretty firmly is that
what maybe it's too
maybe it's too heavy we need to get all
these whoa [ __ ] the sticks are going in
the water that's a problem
if we could please get the sticks that i
spent all that time collecting
please well i mean how much time is this
sticks really worth
i thought it's like 40 or 50 sticks
there sticks on the other side there's
so many sticks
the other side that we could totally get
the sled over to yes
all i got to do is build a bridge
we'll leave the cool bridge and you just
build a secondary
other bridge yeah yeah that's the just
that's the distraction bridge that's the
one
they're not gonna know about that
they'll see the ramparts and the
big strawberry and they'll be like we
gotta cross that one
one trick bridge builders don't want you
to know
yeah is actually
um if you build the secret bridge
[Music]
sounds like i'm laughing but i'm not i
believe you
kaboom let's see no one will know about
the secret bridge
you don't want to know why cause it's a
secret hey mark uh
question yes what's the what do you mean
why what is this
are you talking about secret bridge
because i believe he was going on and on
about secret bridge
i was busy murdering deer and wiping the
blood of it off in the water and i
missed the secret bridge
um how does this in any way help you
missed his explanation no you didn't
yeah i did it they got the
main reason we got the main bridge and
then oh i can walk on logs
i can walk on logs we could build a
bridge out of floating logs
dude that would be so confusing for the
computer that we should definitely do it
we'll have three bridges okay
one for each of us and when the big bad
wolf comes and huffs and puffs he won't
know what the [ __ ] going
on all right see look over here on the
left is the secret bridge
no one will expect us to take that one
we we this
center bridge is so big it's a
distraction every all the
them will be like they're going down the
secret
the main bridge and they won't know
about the secret bridge okay
question mark if i want to build custom
defensive walls
how do i how do you put multiple down
without it like putting the blueprint
down
left click and it'll just like make one
and you keep going
i don't see a way to put doorways in
this i feel like i've been horribly lied
no no i got this i got this watch
listen
[Music]
is that bad bad thing we're fine wade
was overreacting he's
being a bit of a [ __ ] is that a
door is that a door
oh hey this is the secret bridge please
go away thank you
guys if you look through a blueprinted
thing on the ground it's so much
brighter
you can actually see through it
oh you could see through so good oh my
god look at the
daylight over there look at that guy i
can see his nips from here through that
door
i don't even know he's there otherwise
but there he is look at that ass
they're on main bridge though park they
are on main bridge on
but they can't go they ran off into the
water
well they're but i think it's shallow
enough to where they were able to cross
anyway
markets shallow enough they were able to
cross it is shallow enough they were
able to cross anyway
bridge despite the crane being up that's
impossible
that's sounds like it off to where they
just did it
that's like horrifically bad design in
the middle of the river where it was
deepest
i know what an idea but are you all
are you all oh baby i love your way
i'm finishing secret bridges door hey
guys i think we have a visitor at home
oh we have multiple this i can't see i'm
chainsaw and blind in the dark which is
always a good thing
okay here we go here we go uh doing
doink and
that is a door oh that's a door yeah
yeah we need one of those on main bridge
because there's like eight people on our
side
close it
oh oh it's cold oh
that's quite a door i can't see how we
close it from our side
did i build it the wrong way i don't
know mark are you a big dummy
i might have built it the wrong way uh
you know be really cool is if we could
sleep
sleep yeah sleep is good yeah we should
and there's also bad guys on our side of
the camp no reason to worry about that
that's where they wandered why are they
on our side of the camp
uh because crane shallow water
that doesn't make any sense hey friends
hey
oh that's a trap there's a trap in front
of the door wait i don't know
very dark all right uh good night good
night
have i built one good thing mark you
built a lot of good things well look at
the foundation of our upstairs area
oh yeah it's beautiful we should use
that yeah we should
why didn't we think about the fact that
this water was shallow and they could
just
i don't know man secret bridge is the
way to go
okay all right these logs we don't get
back apparently
i'm gonna go ahead and build defensive
wall door on this side too
i think i feel like this bridge and this
crane are still gonna be useful for
something someday cool you're gonna want
to build it 10 logs across
that'll give you two separate sections
on either side so that it's got
clean action you want the pointy log to
be towards you
towards the side our side okay is it bad
if it's more than 10 across
is it more i don't know man
i just know the doors are going to be in
sections of five i'm expanding the
foundation i think
i'm not sure how you made it so tall uh
lots of
fiddling is that the way it's supposed
to look
uh that'll that'll be one door in the
middle that could definitely work but i
like
a grand double door so how does your
double door
let me show you how is that ten i don't
know if that's ten is that ten
yeah ten okay so then blap and blap and
look at that
and then we can put more walls to the
side that are just walls yeah i'm
actually going around it
hey bob we're getting the hang of this
thing we'll have you wood in no time
no time you're going to have wood in no
time
nice everything is going great
okay i don't say grit like that for
anybody i've never heard i'm saying i'm
before
i'm struggling i'm struggling but i'm
trying to i'm trying to match mark's
unm brilliance over here
come on man i don't know if this is
possible using to capitulate
bob you need to come over there what are
you trying to do how the hell did you do
that man
don't get the bridge don't get the brief
oh my god was that my log or yours
if i said yours would you believe me if
i met mine not anymore
can someone come um revive me oh are you
dying
oh yeah i'm on my way mark i cut down a
few trees over there there's like 12
logs or so just chilling i'll go
all right i'll finish this up thanks i'm
don't tell mark what i'm doing his
base what's going on i will just give
you a word of caution about the
mind the gap mm-hmm how's it going over
there guys oh good
feels good okay good that's good how are
you
i'm good you get a look at what he's
doing oh no i was much more worried
about his health i wasn't really paying
attention to what he was working on
oh okay i understand that that's good
friendship comes first whoa
that's nice look at that yeah look at
that
we have a sled over here to see if we
can push one through there now oh yeah
i guess that is a good well oh yeah we
need to get rid of the
oh yeah wait why did we do this
because we already had this bridge and i
didn't want to waste it because it was
so expensive to make and
we'll eventually have a use for this
it'll have a use but we're not going to
be able to push a sled through here to
test
this you know when you're right you're
right why did we do this all right
that's a great question why did we do
this are you morons
doing more on things right the doors are
closed doors are closed
why did we do that i'm trying to goof
around with some
foundation stuff and it's harder than i
thought it would be it's pretty tricky
yeah how's that how do i cancel a build
that i've already placed
hold still look at it and hit c what are
you trying to do i'm just gonna
i was trying to give us like a like a
middle floor like the top is the top but
i was trying to create like a middle
floor over the base
right yeah i don't think that's
practical i can't destroy
this i'm dear mark simonious are you
still around i left
can i call you mark simonious why would
it kind of like it has like a royal kind
of like romanian gladiator feel didn't
it
romanian gladiator i everyone said oh
yeah hold c
yes i understand the concept of the c
button and holding
uh you know what c looks like yeah it's
it yeah it's between the x and the v it
is in fact the letter c
on the keyboard it's like a little
smiley face
but the guy has rotated his head i don't
know if you're yeah i
i was only i could not i got that pretty
easily wade
yeah it should have been i like came
over here and i just did it i
held c so the thing is you need to press
c
on it yeah the c button on the keyboard
right that's the one i think
yeah that was the one perhaps uh do you
want to help me put like a couple of
walls keep dudes from crossing here then
go work on the water why would we keep
working on this bridge well just it's
standing i'd rather things not be like
urban
i'm going to get across your bridge you
know so might as well might as well
polish the old
the old experiment off and just keep up
okay all right i hear you out here you
have to hear you i hear you
okay one on that side and then we'll do
one on this side i do have a lot of logs
i cut over here so there's plenty of
logs to pick up to put in here
cool sounds good man sounds good yeah
this should do okay bob you will get
those logs in two shakes
two shakes you don't need logs what i
need you or
what do you mean you don't need logs i
gave up completely on constructing the
foundation i was working on i don't have
it in me
i'm an idiot i'm saying i know my limits
c oh i thought you said
hey of course i don't see i love this
gate if only this was on a bridge we
could actually use because this is a
really cool gate
it is this gate is oh we could we can
literally just this was our practice we
literally just go do it right here on
this bridge
build another bridge you already have a
bridge how many bridges
are we building today we i
i don't know i got addicted suddenly i
built one bridge and then i had to build
another
wait what's wrong with this bridge
nothing's wrong with that bridge it's
fine
well the one we built the double gate on
this bridge and we can just tear this
gate down build your double gate over
here well no it's not wide enough for a
double gate that's a single gate bridge
that's a narrow secret bridge guys the
blue one it's time for a third bridge i
guess
hell yeah i know everyone was really
concerned but the blueberries
are in fact blooming i i am
very appreciative of that we could
destroy the crane part
if you want no no no no no no no no no
no no i have an idea we'll keep the
crane because it's fun but we'll just
build another bridge
off of this bridge
side bridge that's what i'm thinking you
know when everybody loves a little hot
side bridge
yeah who doesn't who doesn't whoever
built these stairs
sucks a big ass
i'm not saying it was me or not me i
am once again asking everyone to
recognize that i have not been at fault
for much today and that's honestly rare
and i will take the win
no way in hell am i down again are you
down again
maybe no he's fine he's flying oh yeah
he's
working okay cool sounds good my finger
is
sausagey oh man i'm bloated something
bad is happening
really i think i got stung by a bee or
something can i have like a
nibble of your sausage finger you can
try do we have a cart available is there
a cart anywhere that i could use
is it up on the mountain yeah there's
one down here i got one i don't believe
you
mark i literally have a cart down here
at your bridge okay here's what we're
gonna do i need logs for this
part of the bridge you're gonna take the
secret bridge and you're gonna go around
and then we'll
do it that way and then you know once we
have that
we'll be able to use our main bridge oh
look how easy this was
yeah yeah but just imagine how easy the
main bridge is going to be
oh look at this oh that's some smooth
action
all right boys i'm eating all the meat i
tell you what
um what the [ __ ] all right
why did that why did i why did i fall
off this part oh
well because it's not built yeah see
it's not built well no the the new one i
know but like the old one i was just
kind of like
he went too far oh there's oh i'm seeing
the other
i thought i was building on the thing
but i see the [ __ ] old sled down
there
all right somehow astonishingly i need
to cut down more trees but
i think with these we're gonna oh no no
no no no no no no no no no four logs
over here
cutting you're it's done cutting down
incoming hope that doesn't hit anything
it's complete
all right it's complete yep all right
bob
inspect our work dude i love this what's
going on here
with this how does this do something
yeah it opens and closes
oh neat oh my god this is like a
fortress over here i know all right
buttery
look like it was invented by some kind
of
genius person well
don't laugh like that i don't like that
well you know and then oh what the
drawbridge is up
diamonds okay we've got the
nine days later in the engineering
project
to build one small bridge from one side
of one narrow river to the other
is finally complete bob you're over
there gathering wood you're like oh guys
i'm in trouble
mark and i valiantly grab our bows and
arrows we come up here we lift the
drawbridge
we fire on our enemies while you push
through you close the gate look
what enemies counted down the gate we
have these staircases to get the good
angle on them yeah bob that's so
that's the scaffolding bridge is this
one done
or yeah that's a scaffold that we can
tear that out i don't want to point out
any flaws that are
not done being engineered yet but i just
have to say
i feel like the door may not work as
intended
that was a scaffolding we had to build
that bridge so we could get out okay
okay so shall i deconstruct
it really is nothing it's a trash bridge
not like our main bridge the main bridge
really is quite the engineering
feat thanks man yeah the the the lift
the the cat the drawbridge aspect of it
doesn't do a goddamn thing
yeah but it looks so good no no it's
very crucial to our our survival this
part is very important
yeah yeah guys i could have built a dock
we have a dock a dock look
[Laughter]
that looks
and you can make angles in it you can
turn it however you want
is it actually it's in the back it's
called it's called
doc it uh
[Music]
do you wanna do you wanna build the dock
and just see how dirty oh
it's no different our bridge is fine
it's custom
it's custom bridge oh my god you can
have rafts
yeah you can have boats hey guys
idea looking through our stuff here you
know how we have a climbing rope
yeah what if we built a zip line from
the top to the bottom so we could get up
and down
we were down faster hell yeah
yeah i love it yeah we can go straight
from our house up there to the bridge
can i just say mark you built you build
these bridges
like goddamn absolute units over thank
you
nothing a flimsy dock would fall apart
in two seconds
oh i'm sinking into the abyss holy [ __ ]
that's terrifying
what happened you okay if you're
standing on a bridge and you break it
while you're standing on it
you oh that doesn't exist um [ __ ]
jump on my boat listen i'm drowning
are you at fire i know you're over here
oh
wasn't there a fire over here did you
guys destroy the fire i don't know but
i'm out of here guys here it is i'll hop
on the boat i got a torch out
how do you it doesn't go is it because
it turns
hang on wait mark are you turning it i
am turning it
it's not how do i wait oh yeah
oh my god there we go
oh my god whoa can you build like a the
defensive wall on this but not actually
build it so we can see at night
yes put a screen of vision on it that
would be so
good they don't let you build up i don't
know if it's because or because i just
can't build on a boat but i can't
yeah get the car down here bob get the
car down here get closer no i can't put
walls on your boat
no closer i'm as close as close can be
closer it really doesn't get much closer
yeah back into it
yeah you're on in the drink careful
careful oh
okay so go like this mark can you pull
sort of over this way
yeah yeah you see where i'm going i know
where you're going
i already know yeah because you if you
can get it you're gonna
go you gotta go around use the side dock
to get around oh okay i'll use the seat
i'll use a little side dock no worries
no problems
you have to like back up a hair mark so
that way there's something i can't land
there's no no no no oh there is backing
up there is absolutely backing up
there is a hundred percent back up this
thing has reversed are you ready
yeah you ready how's that how's the
lineup you're really good man
yeah yeah yeah hey oh oh there we go
i'm all right i'm gonna have to i'm
gonna have to we're gonna have to
coordinate this i'm gonna have to
push with you ah
mark move under me scoop me up scoop me
back scooping scooping
all right you wrap come all right we got
this all right i'm lined up
i'm lined up wait i don't know if you're
going to be allowed to participate
get on here get out of here it's okay
yeah get get on here and stand near the
back and we might look like
it's going to be all over the place but
stand near the back come on
all right all right okay let's do this
three two one
going oh you're faster than me
there it goes oh no okay that's another
card in the drink
can i drive the rounds yeah yeah go for
it man oh my god this thing rips
i know right we should have built
there's like things in the back of the
book there's uh there's raft there's a
houseboat we could have built a
houseboat
dude i have a new dream look we could
move to the ocean and just live on a
houseboat
what a gondola when the moon hits your
arms recognize pizza pie
lard has a parapet it's got a place to
shoot bows
oh hell yes we need to build build the
biggest floatiest thing
in the book and live on it that's my new
dream can we custom build a raft
can you play raft these are wrap
foundations
you just build you build like maybe some
sort of paddle boat engine
thing and perhaps some sort of rudder
steering wheel
contraption that can build way up high
absolutely yeah
yeah get some radar so you can find
islands if this place you build a raft
and you just sail off into this
yeah does the river connect to the ocean
well we built kind of the bridges
blockading that but
we could just build a new one on the
ocean will you maybe go over it
uh it's a little shallow here my dudes
hang out we have a rock
path from our bridge to our house a
beautiful little rock path
we can make that happen can we build a
gazebo on a boat
i hope so can i put a hole in it bob i
don't think this is gonna work
no it's gonna work he's gotta find the
right angle mark and really wedge it on
there
and then turn it break these shitty logs
no i'm pretty sure they're intended to
be some sort of barrier
okay there's other places why do we have
a pink flag all the way over there dude
did we lose a car is that
that's not a hole where you guys started
building stuff
when everything was terrible we were
trying to build the crane to get the bob
we did get a cart over there because we
were trying to get logs for you right
yes yes yes i'm going to build a camper
this is good so this is going over here
no no no no oh no
but my
in fact we could build a crane to lower
us into the hole probably
wait yeah do you guys want to try that
um
uh ahead of us uh is that bad right
oh god oh god
everyone good oh yeah we're good all
right let's kill it
let's go oh i'm sorry come here you
don't scare me
uh it scares me what about me you don't
scare me
all right fine fine get on then hurry up
let's go back
let's go back and save let's go back and
say okay okay because it's probably a
good idea yeah yeah
if only we could unbuilt defensive walls
with which we could see home from here
uh well it didn't work whatever it just
wants to go in the water it doesn't it
doesn't want to go it doesn't want to be
here because i want to be
wait your torch is more like a
lightsaber and i'm really confused by
that
the fire on your torch is pretty sure
that gravity is going in the direction
that the stick is pointing is there
really no limit to how long this
wall can be this they really had no
limit on walls
it's still good no do it it takes so
long
it takes so long to undo it oh my god
oh my god where does that go behold the
great wall
the great wall of mark oh my god
i don't want to look at it i'm not
looking at it we only need 226 logs to
take care of that
that's totally doable very doable i feel
one
rabbit and i feel great by the way we
could sleep we're just
leading we could yeah it's my birthday
whoa we should have just slept i wasted
a rabbit
good job dummy thank idiot all right
guys
all right you big stupid all right well
unfortunately that's gonna have to do it
for me
go save it then bob saved saved right
now but now we know our mission we made
a lot of progress
this this
[Music]
is that what you call that we destroyed
a cabin
structure house and built a bridge ah
what bark what is this wall
[Music]
anyway gotta go man